this brings us to the question of
privacy and kind of sovereignty around
Bitcoin you are probably one of the
biggest proponents of this mostly
because of the other things you've done
in your life let's just start from a
high level like what does it mean to
have financial privacy and mean to have
financial sovereignty yeah they kind of
go hand in hand you know if you want to
be sovereign you want to be able to make
payments send money without having to
ask permission then that means you can't
have any middlemen that are sitting in
there watching everything that you do
and then potentially blocking what
you're doing the privacy aspect I mean
privacy and security are both both very
complicated things to quantify because
there's a million different variables
and you have to usually start at the
beginning and say well what is your
threat model what are you trying to
protect yourself against because that's
how you then decide what's precautions
you really need to take the big problem
you know with the communication age and
where we are today with the internet is
that people on a regular basis
pretty much every day are sending their
personal and in many cases private
financial information to a number of
different third parties and so over time
that just keeps building up and building
up and each time you give sensitive
information to a third party you're
hoping and trusting that they will keep
that secure so over years and years that
you've interacted with thousands or tens
of thousands of different third parties
then the likelihood that one of them is
going to get hacked is going to leak
that information basically you know
approaches one 100% and so that is why
that's the hard part is preventing that
information from leaking in the first
place and why I've gone to the extreme
of having you know proxy fake
information that I give to all of these
third parties instead and you know you
don't have to go to the extreme of
setting up all these different legal
entities there are services out there
like privacy calm
or you can create unique throw away
debit cards that give you an extra layer
of shielding between your regular bank
account and the merchants for example
but these are all things that are
covered in the resources yeah and so I
guess as part of this when people hear
you say fake information how much of
this is hard to do but legal versus not
legal but worth the privacy right and
legal really what I'm trying to get at
is to have you clarify how much of this
can be done by a regular individual
who's not worried about or who has no
desire to even come close to kind of
skirting the law if you will
versus look like hey I literally just
put a fake address on you know piece of
on a document and if they ever found out
that I would get in trouble yeah you
know this is probably one of the most
unnerving aspects of it is is you know
people are generally they want to be
honest they don't want to get in trouble
for lying and I think that it's actually
covered pretty well in the privacy book
that I mentioned where at least in
America and you know I'm not a lawyer so
don't here check with your own attorney
again I've spent a lot of time and money
on attorneys myself with all of this at
least in America if you're not signing a
legal contract or a legal document or
you're not engaging in some sort of
activity with a government agency then
you can absolutely lie about your name
and your identity like it's not a crime
to give a false name or information
unless it's to you know certain official
authorities or you know something in the
legal sense but to a merchant it is
completely valid to give a fake name and
an address that may not even exist and
in some cases if you get to the extreme
of all of this and you think you've
improved your privacy sufficiently then
like the final step is actually
disinformation
is actually putting your real name and
many fake addresses out into the
internet and hoping that they get sucked
up by all of these information engines
to then create a smokescreen that makes
it almost impossible for someone to
figure out you know what is the real
information